i keep my promises danny you wanted a  boat you got a boat it's a beautiful  piece of [ __ ] but it'll get you to a  junky beach  one with the naked fatties you two are  just gonna let me leave  [ __ ] you could have sold us out a  long time ago  you're my best kid  i can't promise you victory i can't even  promise you survival  what i can promise you is this  you are the lucky one  that usually work  50 50.  i bet this boat will sink halfway  through miami  so  not my fight  despite the tragedy the company promises  that its secretive new resort park will  soon be open to the public  in other news war has ended in europe  president anton castillo announced that  clara garcia the leader of the terrorist  group libertad was killed by his special  forces  and as the pandemic tightens its grip on  the globe the federal government may  impose another nationwide lockdown  but first how about something a little  more upbeat  you